we are very efficiently study what is
going on in ukraine right now and of
course
a lot of lesson learned is involved in
weighted in our this exercise scenario
and
of course it's absolutely necessary and
very speedy speed app to innovate our
this tactics and how
our unit is able to react against this
adversary
first of all of course this is a tactics
which we have to train our soldiers in
such a difficult
circumstances which we see in ukraine
second is the weapon systems you see the
weapon systems which is
used by
ukraine's against adversary is more
connected with wide spread of very easy
and light anti-tank weapons and light
aircraft air defense weapon systems and
of course this is combination of
diversification of use such as this
tactics which is more connected with
partisan warfare but anyway this is more
connected with light infantry tactics
anyway
so the current situation uh really helps
us focus on our major tasks and
understand the why we're here to provide
deterrence and be ready to defend if we
need to and these types of exercises
regularly offer us the opportunity to
practice and it's the same thing now but
as i said with that renewed focus and
definitely all the troops are behind
what we do here and it's very important
for us
you